this program is brought to you by Emory
University the following is in
celebration of Emory's 175th anniversary
brought to you by Emory report hello I'm
Gary Hawk and this is an Emory history
minute in the spring of 1914 a feud
between Vanderbilt University and the
Methodist Episcopal Church south landed
in the Tennessee Supreme Court the issue
was whether the University Board or the
bishops of the church which had founded
vanderbilt had final say over the
appointment of university trustees with
a decision by the court the church
severed its relationship from Vanderbilt
and decided to create a new University
in the southeast the question was where
Birmingham Alabama Atlanta Georgia and
other cities vibed for the honor but the
question was quickly resolved by this
letter handwritten by coca-cola founder
ASA Griggs Candler one of the wealthiest
men in the south it was addressed to his
brother Warren a former president of
Emory College and the leading bishop in
the Southern Methodist Church it spelled
out the need for church related higher
education and offered to the church the
exact same sum that Carnegie had put on
the table 1 million dollars with that
gift and subsequent donations of land
the new University began to take shape
in Atlanta the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University